millennials are the fastest growing
population of home buyers and many are
doing so alone without partners or
spouses we take a look at what's fueling
this trend
a national survey of more than one
thousand homeowners by homeowners
insurance company hippo revealed the
following since march of 2020 sixty
percent of millennials purchased a home
independently
ninety four percent of them saying they
were pushed into it due to the pandemic
sixty eight percent paid over the asking
price and thirty six percent paid a down
payment greater than 20 percent very
many millennials were home by this last
two years and
that particular cohort is just
continuing to grow courtney klosterman
says the generation is dominating the
market the pandemic encouraged many to
find larger space and created the
ability for millennials to save and
place that savings into an asset the
purchase of a home add to that record
low mortgage rates many homeowners are
jumping into home ownership for the
first time feet first and they're not as
prepared as they could be for what's
ahead like those unexpected costs
associated with repairs to a home more
than 80 percent surveyed said they
needed to repair something within the
first year for those eager to enter the
housing market now expect to pay over
asking and more than the gold standard
for down payments and if you can't
afford it on your own she suggests the
following for buyers who are looking at
and don't have a partner consider all of
your kind of financial opportunities
together to the market maybe you speak
to a family member or friend for a loan
and that can help you overcome some of
the challenges